David is great to be with you again over
this time
the book of Acts and as we know that's a
large chunk of the New Testament almost
1/4 of the New Testament is taken up by
this book what kind of book is it and
how does it relate to the gospel that
seems to be associated with it well the
thing that's clearest is it's got some
kind of relationship to the Gospel of
Luke because it's written with a
prologue that sounds very much like the
prologue to Luke and whoever writes it
refers to it as the second volume I
think for our purposes we're discussing
little bit that nobody really knows
whether Luke was Luke that is whether it
was written but I think we'll just call
him Luke because otherwise it was who
was the the Luke that we know about the
New Testament was a companion of Paul's
and also a physician and there's where
do we hear about we hear about him in
Colossians and we we know that he he was
an important figure in the church but
the actual attribution of this letter to
Lou of these of these works to Luke is
later than the works themselves so he
might well be Luke but we're gonna call
it Luke if that's all right I just
rather do that I'd love to pick your
brain on this little bit it's clear that
the two books are closely related to
each other on the other hand they don't
always look kind of planned through
there are distinctions between the two
particularly we'll see in a few minutes
on that the last story of Luke and the
first story of Acts seem to be quite
different versions of the same story
that the story of Jesus assumption so I
what I find myself puzzling is all right
let's say these two volumes are related
did someone plan them from the beginning
and say here's my two volume work did
someone will call him Luke right Luke 10
years later say let's add acts on and
then not worry about the kind of
consistency between all the details
what's your sense of that mmm yeah I
know what you're talking about the there
were continuities and some
discontinuities as well some of the the
continuities have to do with some major
theological themes like the importance
of repentance and forgiveness and
forgiveness which is a major emphasis
both in the gospel in acts and the way
in which share the significance of
Christ is treated I think is parallel a
true
there's also be concerned with things
like wealth and poverty that run through
both of their stacks but yeah there are
some differences as well and I think one
of the differences is they concern in
acts with what we might call apologetic
issues yeah
as what's the relationship between the
Christian community and the Jewish
community of which was once apart
exactly and what's its relationship to
Roman Authority and the Empire and those
concerns I think a distinctive and
fighters who they don't really dominate
the gospel some of them might be there
to a certain extent they they really are
key to what's gonna blow them and and
not surprisingly enact some sense of
what does the structure of the church
look like because you've moved from the
life of Jesus to the life of the church
and how do we organize and how do we
plan and how do we deal with our goods
and how do we deal with our communal
life but if I had to guess and his pure
guesswork I would guess Luke gets
written and then it's new issues emerge
Luke later writes acts as a kind of
important addition to what he wrote at
the beginning rather than sitting down
and saying okay Theophilus I got two
volumes coming here today I think that's
right ax was probably written maybe a
decade or maybe two decades after after
the Congo what what we know about Luke
and antibiotics is that Luke seems to be
the most historically sophisticated of
the Gospel writers he writes more like
an historian you can see echoes in the
in the first verses both of the Gospel
of Luke and in the book of Acts of the
kind of concern and historian has four
witnesses and dealing with sources and
trying to give accurate reports and my
suspicion is that I know a lot of people
who study this more than I have share
that like many historians of the time
he's not to be confused with Arthur
Schlesinger jr. or kind of the whoever
the leading American historians are
today that is it's not that they went
through archives and found dozens of
ancient speeches and put them together
but rather with some clear material in
mind that he's received from his sources
he nonetheless is willing to shape the
story in such a way that it makes the
kind of points he wants to make and
particularly I think that's the case in
acts when we get to the speeches where
after a while Peter sounds like Paul and
I suspect both Peter and Paul sound a
great deal like Luke that they they say
becomes a kind of idealized version of
what Luke thinks they needed to say to
make the points he wants to make which
doesn't mean he's faking it
does mean that he's shaping it to make
the kind of points that fit for his time
his place in his theology
mm-hmm yeah I think that's right I'd
agree and I'd also like people to keep
in mind some of the the facts about
ancient history that there's a spectrum
of the way in which people did that and
even in the most critical ancient
historians people like Thucydides there
was a custom of inventing or fabricating
speeches that would would have been
appropriate to the situation I think on
the speeches what's the kind of
interesting in Luke you're right that
there are some theological themes that
run through them but Luke also I think
tries to create speeches that are
appropriate for the time in a place
order using language and phraseology
that would be appropriate let's say in
the Jerusalem community as opposed to
Athens yeah which we'll see as we get to
the quite different speeches and that
too is a function of the educational
process of the time when people learn in
the art of rhetoric often had to do
speeches in the persona of some ancient
figure and had to adapt their language
to they led to what was appropriate so I
think all of that cultural stuff is an
important part of how Luke shapes his
history and it actually works very well
with what we teach when we teach
preaching classes at Yale which is to
say you worry about the text but the
context to and what you're going to say
will depend partly on the context and
the people to whom you're saying it and
I think Luke models that really from the
very first century for us yeah I think
he's very much concerned with the
audience that they're on they're gonna
continue the message exactly so let's
think about some of the details or of
Acts it begins with the story of the
essential and Luke has already told that
story at the end of the gospel how do
you how do you reconcile these two
different stories yeah I think that's
complicated and the the most obvious
detail difference is that at the end of
the Gospel story Jesus appears and then
a sentence in the big and in the
beginning of the Acts story he stays
around for forty days of teaching and
preaching my suspicion is it's an
attempt to try to make clearer the kind
of strong continuity between the life of
the church and the life of Jesus own
ministry and to prepare us for Pentecost
which comes shortly thereafter and to
say that that what Jesus does during
those forty days is really become his
own transition
between the gospel and the ongoing life
of the church so that this is not it's
not Pentecost is new but it's not brand
new Jesus has helped prepared to wait
for it
partly by promising the spirit but
partly also by himself being a kind of
forerunner of the spirit in those 40
days what do you think I think Luke has
a concern for those issues right and is
trying to get us get a hinge here
between the life of the church and the
life of Jesus I think there were some
other things going on as well Luke knows
from whatever he knows about Paul that
Paul has had an experience the
resurrected Jesus and so he has to
create a space in some ways when that
can happen here though what happens
beyond them right until you say didn't
just appear disappear and that's yet so
I never see me to people so that's very
much yeah but note that it's 40 days and
the appearances of Jesus to the
immediate disciples exclude Paul from
the last building right and this is a
balancing act to that Luke is doing here
he creates a space in which Paul is a
major figure in the life of the church
and that reflects some historical
reality here but he distinguishes him
from the 12 apostles he does and that
category of 12 as defining who the
apostles are I think is Luke's own
adventure auditor and Paul himself call
understood himself to be in a posse I
think Paul would not have been pleased
by Luke's distinction that's right
that's right but having the the
resurrection appearances to the Apostles
end what it is and also so that becomes
a hinder to Paul as well as a hinge to
Pentecost that's right yeah another
thing that pops up right away is that a
group of 12 year and the election of a
new apostrophized
what do you make of that well I do I do
think that the the the number 12 is
important to Luke and I suspect there's
some sense of the continuity with the
twelve tribes of Israel some sense that
that that this provides a kind of sense
of God's ongoing providential care for
God's people which in the Old Testament
is the people of Israel and in the New
Testaments the people of the church and
as you have 12 tribes with 12 patriarchs
so you have a church that has 12
designated leaders
and when one of them turns out to Fink
out or
be the betrayer Judas then the number of
the 12 still has to be figured out and I
think it's partly stressing a strong
continuity between the gospel story and
the story of the church and also the the
business of the choice by lot so I take
it is not just to be what goes well what
happens in Vegas stays in Vegas this is
about random but the belief also an Old
Testament belief that the casting of
lives is a way for God to act rather
than just taking a vote among the
membership and when the lot falls on
Matthias then God has indicated that
Matthias is the one who is to fulfill
the role of the 12 you don't hear
anything about him again I think after
that but at least we've got 12
functioning Apostles again and Paul
ain't the 12th right we don't hear an
awful lot about many of the Apollo great
leaders right Peter and George and
that's about and yeah so the emphasis on
continuity between Israel and the new
people the church that's a very
important thing and the stress that God
is the one in consciousness
what I what we'll talk about more as we
go along and what what puzzles me I
think is how far do the Apostles then
become models for the elders of Luke's
own time and how are we supposed to see
in them kind of pictures of ongoing
church leadership and how much are they
sweet generous belonging to the first
generation then you move to something
different okay one of the major episodes
here is Pentecost yes tell me about that
and why what's going on yeah the
Pentecost as you all will remember and
as you as our friends we remember as
they read these stories is the moment
where the where the gospel is spread for
the first time the good news is spread
for the first time
beyond Jewish speaking people it's not
yet spread to the Gentiles we don't yet
have Hebrew Hebrew speaking Hebrew
speaking Jews all right we're trying to
beyond Hebrew speaking Jews and and
people who normally speak Hebrew or
Aramaic which was kind of the the
version of Hebrew that was familiar to
that time are suddenly able to speak in
all kinds of different languages and
people have come to visit Jerusalem for
the feast from all over the world are
now able to hear this good news preached
in their own language is this
glossolalia this is not glossolalia
glossolalia which we get in first
corinthians is that kind of ecstatic
in tongues where you need someone to
interpret but this is this is articulate
language it's just articulate language
and a whole variety of in a whole
variety of tongues in the sense that
Aramaic and Phoenician and Coptic and
whatever the other options were at the
time our colleague LOM and sound makes a
good point about this that it's kind of
paradigmatic of what the church is a
huge point it's usually one sana says
that what distinguishes Christianity
from Islam is partly that we think the
gospel is translatable that that
scripture in English is still Scripture
that Bible study in in in French is
still studying the same Bible whereas
for Muslim people the Quran is only
Quran in Arabic and that this is a
paradigm of what church is that church
is not finally we're supposed to be the
people of the book we're not the people
of the book in the same way where people
have focused on the single single
language exactly we're people of the
message and the message can be in
different languages don't tell our Greek
students that I won't or our Hebrew
students everyone exactly one last
question in the end of this section of
of Acts we have the first of many many
speeches yeah this is Peters yeah yeah
what do you make of that and what kinds
of themes are sound well something some
things begin to emerge that we're going
to have all the way through one is the
focus on Jesus himself as being the
consummation of God's plan for the world
but interestingly not so much not the
pre-existent Jesus the Word of God that
we get at the beginning of the Gospel of
John but the Jesus who has been active
among them and then most importantly I
think throughout Luke and you can you
can catch me on this stress on Jesus as
crucified in Jesus as risen and and the
crucifixion for Luke is that is a has a
variety of meanings that it does for all
the New Testament writings but it's
partly a matter of convicting people of
sin that it was because of human sin
that Jesus is crucified and therefore in
thinking about the crucifixion people
and in this case especially Jewish
leaders are called to repent and then in
the light of the resurrection people are
on to understand that Jesus is God's
designated representative for the sake
of the world so there's repentance is
the repentant believe in some ways is
carried out by the crucifixion on the
one side and the resurrection on the
other side in the strong sense they are
too to have faith in this one who is
risen
the resurrection is above all God's
validation on Jesus as God's you
mentioned the Jewish leaders that Peter
sort of indict sin this yeah what do you
I think my sense is that it probably
reflects the same history we have in the
Gospels which is extraordinarily
complicated trying to reconstruct how
the crucifixion happened historically is
almost impossible but I think Luke wants
to open up a world where he can one
indict Jewish leaders for the
crucifixion of Jesus to keep the gospel
open to other Jews hoping that at least
for the initial generation they will
come to be believers recognize that
there are pretty good Jews like Gamaliel
and really good Jews like Paul who are
brought into the community but
nonetheless I think he wants I think
what he wants to do is to say that the
Jewish leadership is responsible and
then in ways that we'll see I think he
wants to say that Roman leadership was
not all that responsible back then and
that the Roman leaders are on the whole
people we can get along with very well
now
so part of this apologetic I said we've
got an apologetic I playing both those
worlds against each other you know
okay well we'll look forward to them
pursuing these things when we find a
starting line next to a session thank
you